dinging I can't wait to get back home to
my mom and dad they love me so much
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to more turbo dismount they
added more content since its official
release to the game and now they're so
ok I didn't even do anything yet could
you not go insane before I get there I'm
a little late to the party now ok if
this time you could calm your collective
tits before everything goes to hell I
really want to be there when it happens
don't know why but I'd rather be in the
thick of it I didn't even go down how am
I not making this clear to you I want to
be destroyed this one's called bus
balance and I think I have an idea why
make it okay doing just fine I balance
on that my legs are only slightly
backwards and missing why is your head
upside down sir sorry you handsome
bastard I'm gonna have to ask you to sit
correctly in your seat oh thank you no
that is funky they also added additional
obstacles to the game such as land mines
that doesn't help my situation at all
thanks super slowly get a sneak up on
land mines if finicky watch out okay cut
for you now what are you gonna do with
your life
who did the bus to Disney World I think
it he's something with a bit more power
to get through that land minefield
I'm never gonna make it I think my
crotch just got sploded well there's my
head bye bye me travel it again but no
rain in all that power you know the
horsepower you have don't use this okay
my car hello hello bus no I don't want
to be your friend
it's also a new vehicle my scooty do
well I guess if up is where I wanted to
go Here I am I think that this is
actually meant to be survived
how can anyone make it through this I
can't wear some might think that going
faster is smarter I know that going slow
means death Jesus Megan dad - - dad I
assume you got the men speeding okay
still dead and now for our final trick
we shall channel our inner Knievel
medieval whatever is that okay
you son of a [ __ ] you're just trying to
make me look bad now no it's okay you're
going the piddly slowly oh god okay good
nice trick there okay you're all right
impossible Frogger huh well it's
impossible if new Oh God oh please stop
the chaos something madness yeah I'm on
a fire Chuck something don't look so
okey don't know what's going okay Jesus
Oh
how powerful was that little car let's
watch that again this car hits me I
never think goes to hell the secret is
to grip really tightly with your inner
thighs no oh God oh about my face that's
rush Oh God
how you doing there it's gonna rain lay
spread-eagle here on the highway oh
thank you okay just practicing my splits
hey are you doing ladies out there you
doing good good for you but good I'm
just no no no no no no two pieces a
flitch these crazy crazy speeds breath
oh I'm gonna sue you for everything
you're worth I'm gonna get all the
insurance money out of here
Wow why does he do that to me skateboard
you're my only love I said we call very
okay well you're not gonna get a boost
from that oh wow really hurt bad I'm
gonna make it you may not believe in me
okay I even I don't believe in me what
the hell you gotta be kidding me oh I
got a kid I handle this
that is awesome what's happening here Oh
No where did my head go weightless why
is that happening
all right you take your black magic a D
okay okay oh sorry I did not want to go
into orbit what oh my god you have got
to be kidding me
I love it
oh it's the best that is by far oh my
god I don't even care that I didn't make
it that was awesome I want to use that
for everything you can do there brother
we gonna be fine I'm just driving my
tractor down into the tunnel
what's the worst that could happen well
alright then Oh a mister a boost pad you
say let's just see what I can buy a
mystery turbo pad on the distance
horizon
Oh radical dude a turbo pad it was just
be like sonic Joe mine yo are you
kidding me oh my god that is the
greatest Oh balance it yes please do
look at that I don't care about anything
else
ever I love that so much Oh God oh wow
nice balance there buddy I sincerely do
not care about anything else
this is officially my favorite thing
[Applause]
Wow oh yeah yeah oh yeah you're gonna be
fine don't even worry about just shake
that booty shaking man shake Oh God not
your head your booty
I meant your booty stop taking your head
like that thank you
stop being stubborn little boy and get
your pot across the face don't you give
me that look young man hey sneezy that
sneezy
wiggle the booty god damn you to hell I
just need you to get across the line no
you're gonna die well if you wanted to
hit it perfectly every time you'd be
doing great please yes it's gonna make
it he's gonna be the one go go baby go
you deserve that yes all right so that
was the update to turbo dismount so many
new things and I gotta admit I love this
post more than life itself so check out
the new stuff right now thank you again
everybody for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]